but let's jump into this first story
because I guess it matters nuclear war
nuclear war matters the New York Times
reports a Doomsday Clock moves closer to
midnight than ever the bulletin of the
atomic scientists at the clock at 90
seconds to midnight on Tuesday citing
the war in Ukraine as well as climate
change okay so bubbles
online disinformation and other threats
farts what are they saying is
disinformation where they're like
anything is bad we we really want you to
pay attention to our organization
anything they disagree with or would
inhibit their uh acrement of power
information so so what what the main
issue is that uh Russia is there's war
Russian personalities on TV have
outright said we're in World War III and
they've been saying it for months now
it's been going on for like six months
we're in World War Three just fire the
nukes already and we're sitting here
going like no no no nukes can't happen
nukes can't happen and I'm kind of like
I don't know man I kind of feel like
they could happen and now you have this
um this clock which is
I just I think it's the stupidest well
how long has it even existed that's
right 27. 40. so they think we're even
closer than the Cuban Missile Crisis
exactly and that's well we didn't have
disinformation then it's very important
that we count for modern day
disinformation yeah that's probably the
the big one that's uh I'm bringing the
clock closer you got to take into
consideration you know back when the
Soviets were putting nuclear missiles at
our doorstep they did not have
middle-aged fat men with Maga hats
posting memes there was no orange man to
be worried about was right that's right
and then once Trump came along the clock
just went straight to like one second to
midnight they're like uh Jerome no they
didn't really but uh it was at 100
seconds to midnight look here's the
point there's a legitimate point we made
that we are dangerously close to
Annihilation because psychopaths in both
parties are like Yay war and Kevin
McCarthy's wearing the lapel pin and the
handkerchief like supporting Ukraine
they all want to vote for more funding
to send over there to to instigate more
conflict more than it already is and as
much as I will say outright of course
Russia invaded Ukraine Russia's the
aggressor all that the U.S is not on the
border of Russia Russia is in a border
dispute with a border country on its
border the United States is on the other
side of the planet quite literally why
are we involved in this especially if
it's going to escalate us to World War
III yeah have you seen the ceremony that
they do when they reveal the clock they
haven't covered and they go yeah yeah
and they just like look and they're like
yeah look how close we are you know sick
it's like you're just scared right you
just put a Time on there and they're
like you just made it up and what is
this yeah behind this like how do they
get to like 90 seconds like what fake
information that they're afraid of
versus War like why weren't today at 90
seconds here let's let's let's play the
little ceremony for you guys oh goodness
it's funny because the members I want
you to imagine all these people like
there's five people and they're supposed
to look like academic and smart but
imagine filming this there's a voiceover
and they just stand there for a minute
pull the thing down and then stand there
again the members of the science and
Security Board move the hands of the
Doomsday Clock forward largely though
not exclusively because are they
breathing dangers in the war in Ukraine
we move the clock forward the closest it
has ever been to midnight
it is now
90 seconds to midnight I feel like
that's the title of an action movie like
there's a great song by Iron Maiden
called two minutes because look it's
like we're not scared of that no no look
at this look at this
for 20 seconds they just stand there and
do nothing as we zoom in and they zoom
in and like could you imagine also
someone made that right that's what I
was gonna say like imagine you're you're
like a a props Department you know it's
some you know for some production
company or something and you get a phone
call like can you make a clock that
signals the world is about to end do you
get in trouble if you like leak the the
time
oh no they leaked the the 90 seconds
everyone found out too early but only a
little bit of the clock because we
really got to stress that's what I was
gonna say like has it clearly this is
not the same clock since 1947 like has
it always been like the quarter has it
ever been like more than actually has it
ever gone I've never been further away
it has they probably change it to just a
quarter when when they wanted to make
the impact have more impact was there
something specific that today like we
reached 90 seconds do we reach it last
week like
if there's anything anything policy wise
but I mean I think it's a bad idea to
send Abrams Tanks to Ukraine did you
ever like hear someone count down for
their kid and be like if you don't do
something by the time I count to three
like you're in trouble and it's like one
one two two and a half yeah
and the kids is like I ain't moving I'm
not yeah did they ever break it down to
like you know milliseconds at some point
where like five milliseconds away from
Midnight well because it's relative
right it's never been obviously the
clock means nothing they're saying this
and and you know like like I said like
legitimate point about the pension for
annihilation
but what happens if tomorrow Vladimir
Putin actually fires a nuke and it's a
limited and it's like it's like a
tactical nuke that blows up a military
base so nuclear war has begun are they
going to then be like it's 45 seconds to
midnight I mean what happens if the U.S
retaliates with a nuclear torpedo strike
and like it's 44 seconds 44 seconds and
they're sitting there thinking like guys
we only have 44 seconds left if if we
want to up the clock every time we get
closer to nuclear Annihilation we're
going to run out of seconds no it's like
Bitcoin you just break it down satoshi's
you know you can always just break it
down more we're three-fourths of a
second to midnight are we gonna do
milliseconds yeah yeah so apparently
when it was 17 minutes to midnight this
is what it looked like it's like they
still when was that what year was that
uh I don't know uh this was 19 1991 okay
oh right after the uh follows Soviet
Union right right they were like
everything's fine which was ridiculous
because it's not like there was fewer
nuclear weapons when the Soviet Union
fell it was worse yeah it was worse
because you fell and then Ukraine was
like all of a sudden we have nukes and
then everyone was kind of like uh hold
on there a minute like except for the
Doomsday Clock they were like we're
doing it that's fine it's fine no
worries you know those nukes they left
lying around all over the place after
the collapse of the Soviet Union
actually less likely to be a problem now
um despite we don't know who's
controlling them yeah the Doomsday Clock
is not afraid of that they really are
afraid of whatever Putin's doing and
disinformation I assume it America I
honestly I feel like the Doomsday Clock
is just another piece of propaganda for
uh ngos to use to try to influence
political opinions in in countries that
they don't have actual yeah they don't
that they don't have the ability to
actually influence policy other than you
know to try and get people to vote a
certain way when they watch by it when
they first uh when they first launched
it 1947 it was Seven Minutes to Midnight
and that was that for a year and then it
went to three minutes was that two
minutes hey you got your song as I don't
think it's ever been in the in the
seconds
till now 100 seconds over there wait so
it's never been more than 15 minutes so
they only had to ever do the quarter oh
wait I think I see 17 minutes there yeah
right that was 91. right that's right
that's right that's the farthest we've
been yep after the falling yeah Soviet
Union Falls nuclear missiles are in the
hands of multiple countries nobody knows
where they are Atomic scientists are
like no worries this is fine absolutely
fine you gotta admit though it sounds
really cool it does five minutes I'm
telling you this is an action movie if
the cast Castle doesn't immediately make
this a vlog I will think it's livid it
probably is a movie 90 Seconds To
Midnight no or five minutes two minutes
to midnight is sure
as well yeah I think it might be yeah
but what do you think what do you guys
think about what's going to happen with
Ukraine I mean it's kind of funny that
we're going on to a year into this war
and here's here's the challenge the big
news today was like they found
classified documents at Mike Pence's
house and I just was like I'm just I
don't care this is the third classified
document Scandal they shouldn't have
rated Trump so they went after abide and
I say okay fine if they're going to
write Trump they're going to raid by now
Mike pan says and I'm like just okay
just lock them up it's all of them I
don't care anymore this is just a
symptom of the fact that that Washington
is way too secret heavy they classify
everything they possibly can because
they don't want to have to answer for
whatever they don't have they don't have
to deal with with dealing with the press
or whatever
the the majority
of classified documents and this is just
a guess but I I imagine the majority of
classified documents are not actually
going to if if they were to to be if the
information were to get out it's not
going to put the us at risk the majority
I think they just classify way too much
I'm just saying it's it's the the the
the clock people came out today because
they knew that there's nothing going on
yeah they're like we have our shot in
the media I think more fun to guess
who we're not going to find classified
documents with you know what I mean like
I think Michelle Obama's gonna be fine
Kamala is going to be good there's no
there's no Michelle Obama's in trouble
they're going to find classified
documents with her because they trust
her with things but Kamala Harris they
were like you can you stay over there
there is no part of me that would be
surprised if if President Obama had
classified documents at this point yeah
with Biden and you know Biden stuff
since he was in the Senate and well and
then when they they when Comer today the
head of uh he's the con uh congressman
from Kentucky who's on the head of the
oversights committee and he is
requesting all of the documents the
visitor logs from the Secret Service
from when from uh Biden's house in
Wilmington from the time that he was a
vice president to for for Obama to now
is the is the house in Wilmington the
one that they just found didn't they
claim they don't have visitor logs for
that okay
New York Post this is in April uh filed
a foil across and was like please turn
over your visitor logs and they're like
no no we don't keep any and now they're
saying well we don't keep visitor logs
we do keep a list of people in case
there's like a potential reason that we
may need to know they just don't want to
have to answer the visitor log AKA a
visitor I don't know what you're talking
about here so it's literally the
government just doesn't want to answer
questions the more things they can that
they can classify and just say oh it's
classified just they don't have to just
so that way they don't have to answer
it's not about any sensitive information
it's just a matter of if we go ahead and
classify it then we can we can ignore
the questions and just move along to
focus on whatever the policy that we're
trying to I mean I'm a lot more
interested in why now why all these
people at the same time with these
classified documents it seems really
fishy to me uh why this is happening all
of a sudden so I'm more interested about
like the reasoning for that thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time